[Música]
a lavoura rio por convites empresa que
está com vocês e vai partilhar com vocês
um pouco a minha missão é a minha missão
além de receber o benfica poderia ganhar
é fazer de portugal uma nação estar
tanto permitem corrigir voltar a treinar
portugal nesta quarta depois no século
temos que conquistar tantos e tão bons
os nossos navegadores portugueses eram
na altura os empreendedores
acredito que hoje consegui ser o
navegador novamente tão ambiciosos ou
mais como era nos nas acusações e vou
poder dar também uma recente viagem que
fiz é um país que eu acredito que possa
ser um exemplo para que o que nós
queremos é que o setor realizou em que
acredita portugal também possa ser e
depois vamos partilhar um pouco a minha
história destes últimos cinco anos
quando isso é natural em 2012 e surgiu
um pouco este eureka monte de criar a
une poças e esta viagem por tamanho do
convite da forbes que se colocaram na
cor nada quando diz que também não é só
eu acredito que é muito trabalho mas
também de vez em quando uma ponta de
sorte e que nos convidaram para israel
alguns portugueses e também muitas
pessoas de todas as outras
nacionalidades para irmos é irreal
aquela que é considerada a startup na
china e foi curioso que em três dias
depois perceber como é que um país com
menos de 100 anos de história com menos
população de portugal cerca de 8 milhões
de pessoas conseguiu gerar tanta riqueza
colocar na bolsa nova iorquina zac mais
empresas traz horas qualquer outro país
e como é que em tempos de crise em tempo
de guerra se consegue criar riqueza de
conhecimento em riqueza para o país
e aquilo que aprendi em israel pode
rapidamente traduzir isso também para
portugal a criança nem conheciam ti
sites oferecem um cientista muito maluco
mas também com ideias concretas pelo
país e trabalhava diretamente no
ministério da economia e seu rebento a
ideia de que nós não temos e também em
portugal
depois percebi rapidamente porque eu sou
um bom jogo porque eles querem ser os
meninos têm essa ambição que quando eu
cheguei em 2012
em portugal temos medo de ser otimistas
e meses e grandes e muitas vezes essa é
a tendência de vencer era vista como uma
criança muito negativa
alguém muito arrogante e que hoje
felizmente acredito que esta geração
mais nova que de facto a direção melhor
prata na história portugal pode mudar
portugal é um país muito nela então
voltar para 2012
e quando eu estive fora durante cerca de
quatro anos e quando voltar a portugal
av
curiosamente este artigo chega de
vasconcelos na altura o diretor
internacional do assis que infelizmente
já não está connosco mas que já na
altura e o que acredito na altura não se
conhecia tanto termo estar tanto mas eu
já avisei portugal tem de ser uma nessa
manhã são estar tanto para conseguir
enfrentar os desafios que os enfrentamos
que na altura eram mais graves e do
vapor trumps de inovação e neste time da
europa conseguir tornar um país grande e
realmente em causa e nós vamos conseguir
ser o país é geograficamente mas através
da inovação será um país rico que nós
conseguimos chegar e na altura quando eu
voltar a portugal e às pessoas que
marcaram e continuam marcados
infelizmente o antónio murta que você
jamais vai acontecer daqui a pouco e
alguns problemas já o conhecem
era uma fonte de inspiração que
infelizmente em duas mulheres e dois mil
idosos conhecia ainda muito pouco em
portugal estes trechos temos além de
pagarem foi ontem que não tenha uma
mulher durava até da ag tão boa
são casos este lance promete ser mais
num país que usava já na altura ser um
empreendedor e que nós devemos olhar
para os que este ano comemoramos no
futebol para cristiano ronaldo e
pedágios também algum contest
estamos em plena crise infelizmente pra
esses empreendedores da mãe consegue ser
contra cíclico e percebemos também que
dizer 2002/2003 quando eu voltar e para
2016 e 2017
o mundo melhorou e portugal também
melhorou e acredito também foi vitor
esta nação stalinista que estamos a
criar mas também um país que existia e
acreditava porque meu próprio e vias que
os números e ver esta manhã pelo infeliz
mentores ainda se investe pouco em
investigação e desenvolvimento e está em
condições graves na economia e de se
trabalhar num país que os crimes seja
inovador e com e que gera riqueza
imediata e depois falava muito do
unicórnio e não precisa que esta palavra
da o unicórnio sector a gente querida
hebe se narcisa ser um unicórnio digital
e um unicórnio digital não é um campo
como o no papel mas é assim uma empresa
uma startup tecnológica que tem uma
valorização superior a mil milhões de
dólares
aquilo que eu vi que que num contexto
europeu europa apresentava mesmo muito
pouco aquilo que se passava no mundo e
que os americanos estavam a conquistar o
mundo
o chinês começavam a entrar em um país
muito pequeno queria scream
tinha uma força do continente como
europa não tinha
depois percebi que infelizmente eu não
encontrava na área portuguesa e nenhuma
dessas tabelas que eu achava que nós
temos capacidade para acreditar na
engenharia que nós temos no tablet que
nós temos em portugal incluindo voos
entre as ilhas de java e esta minha
costela portuguesa seria muito muito
fragilizado porque não acreditava que
não se conseguia estar nessa teoria
crédito hoje temos condições incríveis
para consegui las cada
depois tenta justificar quando comecei e
pois tinha 23 anos e toda a gente dizia
não tendo depois que você olhar para os
números e os números dizem que não é
preciso existir este realmente este
momento e eu tenho uma ideia que sabe
que vai ter seis se esforçava as
melhores idéias nunca vão sair do papel
e é importante perceber que com menos de
25 anos que todos e todas estes colossos
digitais foram criados por pessoas com
menos de 25 anos e 900 25 e os 30 anos
esses 90 de momento para para arriscar e
e é preciso que mais portugueses a gente
tem para que os grandes empreendedores
conseguiram escalar positivo uma grande
copa e que era preciso mesmo muito
dinheiro para conseguir lá chegar e que
estes grandes casos em portugal é uma
escala mundial infelizmente ainda eram
pequenos e que em média para conseguir
chegar este unicórnio digital
era cerca de 140 milhões de dólares
plástica ao que uma venda em portugal
nunca tinha sequer atingido e depois
tentar desmistificar um pouco também
este ser empreendedor é ser rico e java
e para onde mais se fica amanhã errava
em meios humanos entre oito e dez anos
conseguir momento que cria uma empresa
até o momento de venda e desde essa
liquidez é e não é fácil e muitas
lágrimas mas aquilo que hoje vivem em
portugal é uma na semana são já
empreendedora eu não diria que é nessa
empreendedora mas acredito que
conseguimos lá chegar mas não é preciso
recriar se aquilo vai a portugal
nós temos que ser nós somos bons e que
tamanha crédito hoje é que nós não
conseguimos em e identificar claramente
as áreas nós vamos apostar e não são
todas iguais
a história de israel consagra-se kit
ficas que eles dominaram eu acredito que
em portugal hoje consegue gerar
tecnologia em dois ou três setores e
sermos os melhores do mundo aquelas duas
outras seitas é difícil ser o melhor
momento e acredita que uma vez estas
gostava que fosse uma em particular mas
pelo menos uma dessas conseguisse um dia
ser uma única hora digital
mas não é preciso ser o único digital
para ter seis e temos que justificar nós
não vivemos hoje numa bolha empresa é
uma bolha empreendedor uma bolha
tecnológica economia é cíclica creche
vai voltar a crescer e nós temos visto
vindo a assistir isso nos últimos anos
mas não vivemos hoje numa bolha
tecnológica
nós temos ainda muito mais tartá pe
ainda bastante mais capital e
curiosamente exitoso mais capital para
investir em startups do czar tanques ou
seja espero que em algumas startups
gestantes poderão levar a comentar mas
não vai tentar usar depois nova ver
novamente vai comprar e há exemplos de
empresas portuguesas que infelizmente
não tem a promoção que deveria ter e que
não precisa angariar milhões e que
angariar milhões não significa sucesso
as fantásticas do empreendedor ainda do
time 100% da empresa e que são casos
chuva antes do sucesso e nós vamos
conseguir também promoveu ainda mais pra
eu e vocês todos acreditarem que é
possível criar grandes empresas
tecnológicas
esse e um de criarmos uma todas as top
10 mundiais a partir de portugal para o
mundo mais orgulha e que é o próximo
passo que o futuro é o uso é que em
portugal
começamos a assistir grandes empresas
internacionais que querem se deslocar a
portugal e extensiva aqui tem gerado
comecei com brindes a francis
quilômetros
o turning points de seppi o ponto de
viragem que permite um ecossistema de
ser local e que consiga atrair
investidores internacionais
empreendedores
sinais e que se consigam todos usar vai
de cheiro e tornaram os tapa uma visão
empreendedora e para não para não
esquecer o bush miguel santo amaro a
partir do saque duas notícias hamburg do
financial times onde ele já a testemunha
que portugal é um caso ses não é
indenização empreendedora mas eu
acredito que vai ser e eu espero
contribuir para isso perca alguns vôos
possam contribuir todos vamos fazer a
partir de portugal pro mundo
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]